foreign
this is your Tech news briefing for
Friday April 14th I'm Zoe Thomas for The
Wall Street Journal
self-driving cars have been a
long-awaited promise of the automotive
and Tech sectors and we're still waiting
more self-driving cars are being tested
in cities from San Francisco to
Pittsburgh but the technology according
to experts is far from ready
so what's the hold up Bart Ziegler wrote
about the future of self-driving cars
for the wsj's journal reports and he's
with me now to discuss what experts say
is stalling its development hi Bard
thanks for joining me hi great to talk
to you you know in San Francisco you do
see a fair number of self-driving cars
on the road but they haven't taken over
the streets yet can you kind of sum up
where this technology stands at the
moment well it's still in a very early
developmental phase those robotic taxis
you may see in San Francisco are
operated under a very special group of
rules they're very limited and they're
closely monitored by the companies
behind them but so far there's nothing
that the ordinary consumer could buy
that would be considered a fully
self-driving car we've been in the early
stages though for a while it feels like
there's been this promise that the next
stage of self-driving is coming soon so
let's talk a little bit about the hold
up you spoke to some experts about this
when did they say fully self-driving
cars are coming our way
well there seems to be a lot of
skepticism at this point whether they
ever will come our way the industry as
you say has invested tens of billions if
not more in autonomous driving over the
past six eight ten years and there's not
too much to show for it they've run into
some obstacles there are various early
levels of what they call driver Assist
Technology like many cars a day have
adaptive cruise control which regulates
the car you're driving so it won't get
too close to the car in front of it they
have what they call Lane keeping assist
which can Center your car in the lane
you're traveling in and if you steer out
of it it'll steer you back in but that's
about the extent of it there's some
higher end cars that do allow you on
certain highways that have been mapped
and sometimes photographed to allow you
to use hands-free driving
but these cars typically monitor you to
make sure you're ready to take control
if your eyes Wander from the road they
will notice that and you know set off an
alarm so you start looking at the road
again so this sort of promised level of
fully self-driving autonomous cars where
the driver literally could take a nap or
watch a movie or sit in the back seat
it's just not there all right well let's
talk about some of the technology that
might help us get there
what needs to change then within the
self-driving cars to make them do more
than just assist us in driving well
today they have the cars that do have a
bit of assistance they rely typically on
radar and cameras and they do a fair
amount of telling the car where it is
where the relationship is with a highway
and other vehicles but to be fully
self-driving they need some other
systems typically this one called lidar
which is a laser-based system that
basically shoots out laser beams you
can't see but they're shooting out from
the car every direction and can map an
entire representation to where the car
is where other vehicles are if
pedestrians are crossing the street it
creates a map the car can use to safely
drive the other component behind all
that is artificial intelligence and
that's where the experts I spoke to said
a fair amount of work still needs to be
done to really capture what the human
brain does AI would need to be vastly
more sophisticated than it is today to
typically the day's AI systems rely on a
database of driving situations that
they've captured and and sort of can
work from them to figure out what's
happening in real time
but one of the problems is they cannot
map every possible scenario of a Car and
Driver they're what they're called edge
cases that the systems haven't mapped
such as your driving and suddenly a dog
runs in front of the car or suddenly a
road worker stands in front of you and
puts up a handheld stop sign these cars
rely on past scenarios may not know how
to handle it and could abruptly jam on
the brakes which could cause a rear end
collision with a car behind it or they
could try to steer around it so that's
one of the main concerns how you deal
with these edge cases we're seeing
more sophisticated though you know
certainly there's concerns that AI is
going to do lots of other roles that
humans do at the moment and driving
feels pretty simple you know when most
of us get behind the wheel it's pretty
intuitive so why couldn't AI just take
that on well it turns out the human
brain does an amazing number of things
when you're driving and experienced
drivers don't even think about it you're
making Split Second decisions should I
speed up should I steer around something
is it safe to make a left turn at this
intersection or not your brain has an
amazing amount of processing capacity
and inputs from your eyes and your ears
and your experience that are awfully
difficult to mimic with artificial
intelligence the experts I talked to has
said there is ongoing work and what's
called detecting human intent which
would be ways to read human Expressions
body language Etc but it's very early on
and when expert said these techniques
are far from foolproof so that that is a
very important area and one that faces a
number of challenges we talked a little
bit about the technology
ours are there any changes
changes on our roads or Highway
driving more of a reality the experts I
spoke to said that is an important
component of future autonomous driving
and it's in the very early stages
there's a technology they're working on
that would connect a car to say traffic
lights and weather reports and police
accident reports and eventually car to
car communication where one intelligent
car could communicate with another and
it could help the car you're driving in
have a better sense of what the cars
around it will be doing but there are
only very early versions of that and one
issue is some of them aren't compatible
with each other and the experts told me
it could be quite expensive to rewire
our highways to have all these signals
being sent out by things along the
roadside all right that's Bart Ziegler
who wrote about this for the wsjs
journal reports thanks for joining us
Bart you're welcome and that's it for
Tech news briefing this week tnb's
producer is Julie Chang we had
production assistants from Zoe Culkin
our supervising producer is Melanie Roy
and our executive producer is Chris
sinsley I'm your host Zoe Thomas thanks
for listening and have a great weekend
[Music]